- Good morning everybody.
So most of you know
that Christina Seyfried
is the head teaching fellow in the course.
But what you don't know about her
is that she's writing a dissertation,
she's an advanced graduate
student in political science
writing a dissertation
about China in Africa.
And has spent much of the
last two years in Nigeria,
Ethiopia, South Africa and elsewhere
studying just what the
Chinese are doing there.
She is also the brains and energy
behind Yale's China-Africa initiative
that has been going on for
the last several years.
So it seemed absurd for me
to be giving this lecture
when there's somebody who knows
in such more intricate detail
about what's going on then Christina so,
Christina, welcome.
The floor is yours.
(audience clapping)
- Great, thank you so much, professor.
Welcome, everyone.
I just wanna say I feel extremely honored
to be giving this lecture
today on China in Africa,
especially because my journey
really with this topic
started three years ago.
In my first semester here at Yale
when I took a class with Professor Shapiro
at the business school,
and one of the lectures
was on China in Africa.
And I found the topic
extremely interesting.
And I started to read more about it.
But I was a little bit
not completely satisfied
with the rather China centric angle
that literature was taking on the topic.
So I decided to write my dissertation
on how African governments strategize
around Chinese investments
in their countries.
And I spent 10 months
of doing field research
now in the African region.
And as I said,
I feel extremely honored now to be back
and to be standing on the other
side now of the classroom,
and to teach a lecture
on China-Africa myself
and to share some of the
lessons from my research
with you today.
So to start us off,
I brought you a video from the forum
on China-Africa cooperation,
that just happened in
September of last year.
And China started these forums in 2000.
And they have been
happening every three years.
And China uses them as a platform
in order to announce
a strategy for Africa.
So in terms of loans, trade and investment
for the next three year period.
- [Woman] Building a
community with a shared future
and seeking inclusive growth,
the opening ceremony of this year's summit
for the forum on China-Africa cooperation,
saw President Xi Jinping
outline his vision
for China's ties with the
African continent in the new era.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Translator] China is the
largest developing country
in the world, and Africa is home
to the largest number
of developing countries.
China and Africa have
already formed a community
with a shared future.
We stand united with Africa's
people thinking with one mind
and working with one heart.
- [Woman] President Xi
Jinping has announced
eight major initiatives
in the coming three years.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Translator] The framework of the
10 major cooperation plans,
China will work closely
with African countries
and implement eight major initiatives
in the next three years and beyond.
It feels like industrial acceleration,
infrastructure connectivity,
trade facilitation,
green development, capacity
building, healthcare,
people to people exchanges,
and peace and security.
(speaking foreign language)
In order to promote the
successful implementation
of the eight major initiatives,
China will provide $60
billion in support for Africa.
For government assistance,
financial institutions,
and financing from Chinese enterprises.
It will include $15 billion in free aid,
interest free loans,
and concessional loans.
$20 billion in credit funds,
$10 billion in China-Africa
developmental financing,
$5 billion in special funds
for import trade from Africa,
no less than $10 billion in investment
from Chinese companies
over the next three years.
- [Woman] Already the summit has passed
two outcome documents,
including the Beijing declaration
and the FOCAC action plan 2019 to 2021.
Participants say that in a
current era of globalization,
all nations have a common destiny.
And to put it in the
words of President Xi,
everyone has in himself,
a little bit of others.
- So as you can see,
a lot of big announcements
were made at this forum.
And this last image here has
actually become very famous
because for the first time in
the history of these forums,
53 out of 54 African
countries were represented.
And I remember an African
newspaper called Africa News
wrote at the time that this was the week
where the African continent
was bereft of its leaders
because everyone was
hanging out in Beijing.
So this is just really
the most recent peak
of China-Africa relations
that have gained more and more
international attention from
practitioners and academics
over really the past 10 years or so.
But why is it that this
has become such a hot topic
from a developmental point of view I mean?
And in order to answer this question,
I would like us to take a
step back and think about
what are the African regions
persistent growth obstacles?
And I brought you a comparison
here from 1982 to 2016.
And you see in the 1980s,
China really was poor agricultural,
and had just emerged out of
a series of intense conflict,
namely the Cultural Revolution.
And you see that China was in fact poorer
than most African countries,
except for Guinea Bissau and Uganda.
But fast forward to 2016,
China is now richer than
most African countries
except for Equatorial
Guinea and the Seychelles.
And I know in lecture four we
studied very much in detail
China's growth miracle.
But what was meanwhile
happening in the African region.
So after decolonization,
several African leaders
starting in Nigeria,
Zambia and Tanzania,
tried to import substitution
industrialization.
And that means you
basically keep your economy
closed to international trade
and you try to grow and
develop local industries first
that compete within the domestic market.
But that is an economic
growth recipe really failed.
So after several debts and oil crisis,
the IMF and the World
Bank stepped into Africa
and implemented so called
structural adjustment programs.
And the idea was that
everything needed to
solve Africa's poverty
was real neoliberalism through
the Washington Consensus.
So deregulation, privatization,
and liberalization.
And after that, everything
would fall into place.
But that logic was flawed.
And even after these
countries went through
structural adjustment programs,
foreign investors weren't really willing
to come to Africa still.
So at the turn of the millennial,
Jeffrey Sachs who was a very
famous economist at Columbia.
He also worked on the
Millennium Development Goals
with the UN.
He wrote this famous piece on Africa
being caught in a poverty trap.
And what he's saying is
that because of diseases,
low stocks of human capital, technology,
high transportation costs
and an adverse geopolitical location,
Africa is really stuck
with both weak growth
and weak institutions.
And we have studied the
modernization theory that says that
growth supposedly leads
to strong institutions.
But the question here
is what leads to growth
in the first place.
And he's saying that foreign investors
don't want to come to the African region,
because they aren't strong institutions
that could enforce property rights,
the rule of law, et cetera.
And he's really advocating for aid
as the solution to Africa.
And there are economists
such as William Easterly
or Dambisa Moyo who highly
criticize this call for aid
as a solution for poverty.
But it remained the fact
that the African region
wasn't able to attract much investment.
And then, with the wake of
the financial crisis in 2008,
it looked even more dire
because you have the collapse
of the Washington Consensus.
And if this hit to this
overconfidence and neoliberalism
as a concept and then the
solution to end poverty,
and you really see a retraction
of Western investment in Africa,
also because the West is
running capital shortages,
as they have to bail out banks at home.
So now the question is,
where can Africa attract
investment from now?
But as Deborah Brautigam in her book
that you were also supposed to
read for this lecture today,
predicted, China meanwhile is rising
and is running huge capital surpluses.
So where others are exiting as
the path of least resistance
going back to Hirschman,
who we have studied as well.
China now fills the void
that the West is leaving
and increases its presence in Africa.
Hence we know that China has
lifted millions of people
out of poverty.
And I would really
recommend this book by Ang
"How China Escaped the Poverty Trap".
So now the question is, is
China just a new colonialist?
Or is its presence going
to add something beneficial
to the African continent?
And as I walk you through the slides,
I would like you to think
about this question,
whether it is even the
right question to ask
and I'll also offer you my
opinion, as we move along.
So for today's agenda,
I will provide you with
a quick historic overview
on China-Africa relations,
then I'll give you a big picture
of what China is doing in Africa today.
And then we'll dive
into some key questions
that I think are important to
ask about this relationship.
And I will use two case
studies, Nigeria and Ethiopia,
which are among the top receivers
of Chinese assistance in Africa.
And then I'll talk about some
lessons and I wanna bring up
this idea of African bargaining power here
and how much African agency
matters in this relationship.
And then finally I'll
give you my two cents
on where I think this
relationship with China
is going in the future.
So a lot of people think that
China really started to become
present in Africa in the early 2000s.
When in fact, we have to go
back to the end of World War II.
And African countries are
slowly becoming independent,
while China is meanwhile fighting
its own domestic conflict,
where the communists had just driven out
the nationalists to Taiwan.
And Beijing, China is
now looking for allies
in this Beijing-Taiwan conflict.
And after independence,
14 African countries
actually decided to
side with Beijing here.
And we have very skillful leaders
like Sekou Toure in Guinea
who played the United
States and the Soviet Union
against each other in their aid offers.
And then he secretly accepted
$25 million from China
on the backside.
China at that time is
also rewarding socialists
and communist movements as in Guinea
but also in Ghana and Mali but
after the Sino-Soviet split,
which was basically about
personal differences
between Mao Zedong and Nikita Khrushchev,
but also different
ideological interpretation
of Marx Leninism.
Sorry, Marxism-Leninism.
China has an interest in keeping
up this non aligned world
that neither sides with the
US or the Soviet Union here.
And what's really
interesting is that in 1971,
Beijing, China is actually
able to gain back a seat
at the UN that had been
previously occupied by Taiwan.
And Tanzania was very, very vocal
here in these negotiations.
So we studied how in 1978,
China opened up its borders to the world.
And it officially starts
its bringing in period
where it is trying to attract
as much foreign capital as possible.
And what's really striking
here is that China
is the only developing
country in the world
that is also offering aid to
other developing countries.
And the strategy here is very much based
on its own experience as an aid recipient
for example from Japan.
That during that time knocked
on China stores and said,
we'll offer you low interest,
low interest loans for
technology and material
and in exchange for crude oil.
And we see very similar
deals still being made today
between China and Africa.
And we studied how China
was able to rise very fast.
So starting in the early 1990s,
China's running huge capital surpluses
and is officially entering
this going out period,
that we're still in today.
And China is trying to
put its capital abroad,
to invest it abroad,
and it really uses its
aid as a strategic tool
to promote Chinese exports,
and to help Chinese infant
companies really grow and learn
in other countries.
And it also positions itself
sort of as an alternative to Western aid.
So in 2005 in Tanzania President Mkapa,
he really when he stepped down,
wanted to give his population kind of
as a departure gift, a football stadium.
But the problem was that Tanzania
was on the list of highly
indebted poor nations.
And they were supposed to
actually run austerity measures,
and couldn't spend all that money.
But then he went to China and China said,
okay, we're willing to build
you that football stadium.
It's gonna be smaller, but
we're still gonna build you one.
So he was happy.
But what's very interesting
is that in the early 2000s,
China seems to have accepted
the rules of neoliberalism.
And the US is an economic
headroom at that time,
because it joins the WTO at
a lot of pressure from the US
and it seems like it wants to play
by the capitalist international rules
that were set up by the US.
But then as we studied the
financial crisis hits in 2008,
and this is also a hit
to this overconfidence
that neoliberalism is
sort of the way to go.
And it gets a lot of affirmation
to the Beijing, China model
which is the state capitalism
and that it sometimes it's
better if the government
owns companies in a certain
sector that is deemed strategic.
And if you have large
infrastructure investments
and that sort of an
interventionist approach
by the government is more effective
than leaving everything
to the private market.
And an embodiment of this new confidence
that China has found
is the Asian Infrastructure
Investment Bank,
and the Belt and Road Initiative
that I'll talk about in a little bit.
But I would really recommend
this book by Kurlantzick here,
where he also talks about the
effect of state capitalism
and the spread of it in
today's world on democracy
if you're interested.
And as I said, the most recent peak
of China-Africa relations
has really been this
FOCAC meeting of 2018
where you saw the clip,
where really China is trying
to rebrand this relationship
with Africa and it has signal
that it's been listening
to the concerns about
debt traps, et cetera.
So it seems like the
relationship has matured
or that's at least the narrative about it.
So what is China doing an Africa today
and I'll briefly walk you
through loans and trade,
which are oftentimes in the news.
But then I also wanna
talk about investments,
which is what I'm focusing on
and it's a smaller sector
of Chinese involvement,
but growing.
And then I'll also talk very briefly
about China's military presence in Africa.
So China's loan strategy in Africa
is very much based on this
idea of state capitalism,
that you need to take a lot of
money into your hands first,
and invest in infrastructure and sort of
get in the early stages of development,
kind of the state to make growth happen.
And as we know,
African countries sometimes
have shortages of money.
So these loans serve that they
lend to these countries now
so that they can build infrastructure
which is pre-stage of industrialization,
in order to make growth
and development happen.
And just to give you an idea
of how big these loans are today,
we see that really,
the loans from the China Exim Bank
are already competing
with World Bank loans.
So the same magnitude that
we're talking about today.
But there's a big difference between
World Bank and Chinese loans,
namely that World Bank loans
come with strings attached.
So this is based on the structural
adjustment programs today
so we have austerity measures,
and if you're expected
to have fiscal prudence,
where Chinese loans really
have no strings attached.
And a lot of people are
concerned about this
because if this money gets
into the hands of politicians,
they could misuse this,
could also be a way of China
sort of making African countries
more dependent on itself.
Or it could also be kind of
China thinking long term,
it gives loans to countries
that can't pay back these loans.
And then it can take over, let's say ports
as it happened in Sri Lanka in 2017.
And we'll talk about
this a little bit later
whether these concerns are justified.
So China also gives us
these loans as part of
the Belt and Road initiative.
And this initiative as I
said, was launched in 2013.
And it is part of China's going out
and going global strategy.
And China right now
is building trade
infrastructure in Eurasia.
And it's really meant to
build trade routes in Eurasia,
that is going to compete with
the Transatlantic trade route
that is currently being
dominated by the United States.
So here you again see this
confidence that China has
in its own development approach.
And what's interesting,
China's already Africa's most
important trading partner.
And you can look at these
graphs, I'm gonna post them up.
But really, the essence of this
is that China is exporting more to Africa
than Africa is exporting to China.
And that was also one of the big topics
that the FOCAC of 2018
that China was asked
by African countries to also
import more from Africa.
So as I said,
loans and trade kind of
dominating the headlines,
but Chinese investments in
Africa, also a growing sector.
So you see that the United States
and the former colonial powers
is still really leading here.
But if you look at a change of five years,
they're pretty stable.
But when you look at China,
this is really rapidly increasing.
And I really like this graph here,
which is the comparison between
US and Chinese investment flows to Africa.
And when you look at the blue line here,
I think it shows very nicely that you have
an upward sloping trend line
until the financial crisis
and then under the Obama
area, those flows really drop.
And now if we could extend
this to the Trump area,
Trump he focuses more, he
has more military concerns
than kind of foreign direct
investment priorities.
But when we look at China here,
you see an upward sloping trend line
and there's one outlier.
That's when China bought 20% of the shares
of the Standard Bank in South Africa.
But I think the essence of this graph
is really external shocks
really don't matter
as much to investment flows of China,
and also changes in political
leadership, et cetera.
So I think this shows that
China intends to be in Africa
for a longer, longer future.
And we can't say really
the same about the US,
we don't know what's gonna happen.
And here just to give you an idea,
investments, Chinese investments
in Africa, very diverse,
and the biggest sectors are construction,
transportation, manufacturing.
And I think this really
nicely fits into Sun's story
of the Flying Geese Theory
and the geese flying to Africa now.
Where we have talked about
the Flying Geese Theory
a little bit when we talked about China.
Capital basically moves to
wherever labor is the cheapest,
and we saw Japan
industrialize in the '50s.
And as labor prices increase there
they moved to other areas in East Asia.
And now because labor is increasing,
labor prices are increasing
so much in China.
We see a lot of Chinese
manufacturers moving to Africa
and actually, I conducted
a lot of interviews
with Chinese manufacturers in Africa,
in Nigeria, Tanzania, Kenya,
other places that are really said,
I'm here because this looks
like China in the '70s.
And it's really amazing labor
is so cheap, land is so cheap.
So officially, China's
saying that it is interested
in an economic and sort of
cultural exchange with Africa.
But people are getting
more and more concerned
also about China's military presence,
because right now China is already
the Security Council member that deploys
the largest amount of troops
under UN command in Africa.
And what you need to know here is that
African countries don't really like
if soldiers from neighboring
countries are deployed
inside their countries because ethnically
which is oftentimes
cross national borders.
So now the AU, the
African Union and the UN
might like to employ and
have Chinese military
stationed in these countries
to avoid this problem.
And then China also set up
its first military base in Djibouti
that also raised a lot of
concerns and I have a little clip.
- [Woman] A fleet of
Chinese ships en route
to the Horn of Africa on a mission
to set up China's first overseas
military base in Djibouti.
China's is the base will be used
to support peacekeeping
and relief missions.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Translator] The
establishment of the base
will help Chinese vessels escort missions
in the Gulf of Eden and Somalia
and international obligations
such as humanitarian rescue missions.
It helps China to continue to make
even greater contributions
to the peace and stability
of Africa and the rest of the world.
- [Woman] Construction
began on the base last year.
Although small, Djibouti
is strategically placed,
sitting on a busy shipping route
and a stable country in an
otherwise volatile region.
China now joins the ranks
of several other nations
with military bases in Djibouti,
including the US, France and Japan.
But China's new base and rapid
modernization of its military
is raising alarm bells
for neighboring countries,
particularly India.
With concern this base
could become another one
of China's so called string of pearls,
building up strategic military alliances
and sea lanes in the region.
- So I think we can all agree
that whatever China's doing in Africa,
it's a very wholistic strategy.
And China has really increased
its presence in Africa
in the early 2000s.
And it seems like it wants to stay
for a near and medium future.
So I think there are a
couple of key questions
that we should be asking
on this relationship
that really try to get at
what are China's intentions
but also what is in it
for the African side.
So first of all, going back to
our central question from the beginning,
is China a new colonialist?
Or is this presence adding
to local development
on the ground in Africa?
And are the final colonialists
here by a foreign power
that tries to take partial
or complete political control
over another nation,
as well as engages in
economic exploitation?
Then the second central question is
how does China's presence add
to institutional development?
So sort of more on the political side.
Does it have good or bad governance?
Thirdly, are debt trap claims justified?
And these are all
questions that really media
and scholarship has been
trying to analyze and answer.
And I would like to throw
in a fourth question,
which is how much bargaining
power do African governments
have in their relationship with China?
And how do they use it?
Is there leverage on the
African side to influence
what this China-Africa
story might look like?
And so on this key question of China,
is China new colonialist,
China's officially running
a five nos policy in Africa.
So it's this five nos
policy is very much based
on its general policy of non intervention.
So that's also why China is not supporting
the responsibility to protect or to keep
because it's basically saying every nation
is responsible for its own population.
And we're not going to intervene
with anyone else's affairs,
as we also don't want anyone
to step into our domestic politics.
That's also why China oftentimes vetoes
sort of intervention.
So resolutions at the UN,
also with Syria for example.
So here you see Xi Jinping
talk about his five nos policy
in Africa.
(speaks foreign language)
- [Translator] China values
sincerity, friendship
and equality in pursuing cooperation.
The over 1.3 billion
times people have been
with the over 1.2 billion African people
in pursuing a shared future.
We respect Africa, we love
Africa and support Africa.
We follow a five no approach
in our relations with Africa.
No interference in
African countries pursuit
of development path fitting
their national conditions.
No interference in African
countries internal affairs.
No imposition of our will
on African countries.
No attachment of political
strings to systems to Africa.
And not seeking of selfish political gains
in investment and financing
cooperation with Africa.
- So you see here China's
official stance on this is,
of course, we're not a new colonialist.
We're not interested in
kind of political control.
We're just really as I said before,
interested in economic
and cultural exchange.
But of course they're
also more critical voices
on this China-Africa relationship.
And I brought you here a comic
by a famous South African artist.
And you see basically China coming in
with those big machines,
and it says China's
industrial colonialism.
And these machines are going
against the local population.
And here you also see,
Africa's environment
is also suffering from
so the expansionary vision
of China and Africa.
And when you look at
Western newspaper reports,
there are also a lot of articles like on
Chinese debt trap diplomacy
again with those loans,
economical cold war.
Is it a new colonialism?
Chinese investments bring
racism and discrimination.
And I also talked to
locals that have told me
that the Chinese they
just take all the jobs.
So it really, everyone is
split about this topic.
So I would like to have
a poll now on sort of
from your background
knowledge on China and Africa,
what do you have heard
from the news, et cetera,
who thinks that China is a
new colonialist in Africa?
Okay, that's a lot of people.
I didn't expect that.
So who thinks China's influence
in Africa is really kind of
they're actually better than what
the former colonialists have done?
Okay, yeah.
And who was split on this topic?
Yeah.
So I think the vast majority thinks
that China is the new colonialists.
So I'll just give you my
opinion on this issue.
So I think if China is a new colonialist,
which I actually doubt is,
first of all, it is a very
different kind of colonialism.
Because as you've seen
in that famous image,
53 out of 54 African countries
actually deliberately selected into it.
So it wasn't like China,
just coming to Africa
and kind of taking over political control.
but it is they are offering
deals and the Chinese side is
can either accept them or not.
And there are a lot of
speeches from African leaders
from this forum that talk
very favorably about China
and how their relationship
is different with China
than with the West because
of this non intervention.
We also talked about how altropy is
is sort of Europe centric.
And it could also lend itself to again,
like colonialist aspirations, et cetera.
So this is sort of an agreement here.
But I think obviously,
the Chinese government,
the West and African leaders,
they're self interested actors,
and they're very irrational
in sort of what narrative
they put out there.
So I think instead of listening
to what different leaders
are saying here,
we should focus more on
impact and the variables
that we can actually measure of what China
is doing in Africa.
And I think there are three
questions that are probably
the most productive to focus on
if we want to have a real assessment here
of whether China is a new colonialist.
The first one is, is China helping to grow
and diversify African economies?
And this one is really important
from both an economic
development perspective
but also from an
institutional one and also
in terms of democratic one.
First of all, economic
one because we want to see
with China's presence in Africa,
are African countries that
are mostly agricultural now,
are they moving more towards industry?
And from an institutional perspective,
I know we started to risk it all in detail
where they're all saying
we can't really predict
when a democracy,
like when the transformation
to a democracy
becomes more likely.
But what can we say about its survival?
So we know that democracies
are more likely to survive
if they have a higher per
capita income than $14,000
as well as they have
a diversified economy.
And then I want to ask two
more questions, which are
is China adding local human
capital and technology?
And how does the competition
with local businesses look like?
And these two questions
are really inspired
by China's own growth miracle,
because when China opened up in 1978,
it invited a lot of foreign investors
and provided incentives, all of that,
to come into specific industries.
But what's very interesting
about China is that
it actually kept a pretty strict
foreign investment catalog,
where it laid out certain sectors
that were completely restricted
to foreign investment
and others where foreign
investment was allowed
and encouraged but had
caps on foreign equity
that was allowed for a
joint venture requirements
and also requirements and how
many foreigners were allowed
on the boards of companies.
So they're much I summarize,
this is local participation requirements.
And China was using them
really as a magnifier effect
because China was able to import
the technology from abroad
and get the money from abroad,
but it built a second of local managers
that could then run the show.
And this is also one of the explanations
as to why China was able to
grow and develop so fast,
because locals learned
very much and very fast
from foreigners in their countries.
And before I dive into my case studies,
Nigeria and Ethiopia,
I just wanna point out that,
this idea that there's One China
Inc. Africa is also flawed.
So I know we talk about China and Africa,
now also use the term just
for simplicity reasons.
But through my research,
I found that there actually
at least three different types
of Chinese companies in Africa
that have very different
incentives that are worth studying.
So first of all, you have
state owned enterprises,
and they're very much linked to
China's sort of state capitalism model.
They are very dependent on the
Chinese government's control.
And oftentimes, they're both
driven by an economic incentive
as well as sort of a different diplomatic
kind of relationship,
let's say between China and
Nigeria where these companies
are allowed to operate at
razor thin profit margins.
If this is important enough
for the strategic relationship
between an African country and China.
Then you also have big
private firms like Huawei
who come to Africa to really
they're very profit driven.
I've talked to CEOs from Huawei
who really want to compete with
Western companies in Africa.
But they have such a high profile
that they can't really hide
from the Chinese government.
And so they're still dependent sort of,
on China's, the Chinese
government's strategy in Africa,
and they can just do everything they want,
because China's actually very concerned
about its image in Africa.
So they have still have
to obey by certain rules.
And then there's a third category
which I particularly find
very interesting to study
which is small, private firms.
So how they come to Africa is in two ways.
So sometimes you have Chinese
state owned enterprises
being sent to Africa.
And then employees in the
state owned enterprises
are realizing, okay,
we're not really making any money.
So individual entrepreneurs,
they venture off
and they open a small company in Africa
to really make more money than
that sit on the enterprise.
Or we have some small
Chinese private companies
already in Africa that do have
friends back home in China.
And they will tell them all
like land here is really great.
Like here, the taxes
really low, et cetera.
So you should come from China to here.
And they keep a very low profile,
and they hide a lot from the
Chinese government as well.
But what I would also like to add is
the Chinese government doesn't
really care if they hide
or not as long as you're not
big enough to really matter.
And if you make an impression,
if like your company screws up
and it's gonna be in the news and stuff
that could be could influence
this image that China has in Africa.
So I also talked a lot
of two or three types.
And as I said, they all have
very different incentives.
And that matters for the stories
that I'm going to tell you now.
So let's first focus on Nigeria.
So Nigeria as a country in West Africa.
And just to give you a little
bit of background on Nigeria,
it has the largest population in Africa,
and also one of the largest
youth populations in the world
behind China and India.
And it's a former British colony,
and it went through a military period,
military regime period.
And it's been formally
democratic since 2015,
when Jonathan Goodluck
deliberately stepped down
to Muhammadu Buhari and
democratic elections.
And Muhammadu Buhari he
just ran for a second term
in February and I was
actually in the country
during that time.
So it was very interesting to observe.
So what's really interesting
about Nigeria is that
in the '70s and early '80s,
it actually had the largest
textile industry in Africa.
So we had some diversification
of the economy happening.
But when we fast forward to today,
80% of all finished
consumer goods are imported.
And really, the economy
is not diversified at all.
So what happened there?
So in 1958, Nigeria discovered
oil, and by the 70s,
this was really the largest
sector of the economy.
And I think that led to
really three outcomes.
So first of all, as we
talked with the Soviet Union,
if there's one dominant
sector in a country,
the political elites really
have an interest in keeping that
one sector dominant because
they can grant access
to the sector and they
can make a lot of money
versus if you try to diversify the economy
and try to provide
alternatives to the population,
they would not pay you anymore
to get access to the sector.
Secondly, there's also the
Dutch disease and basically
as your revenues increase
in one particular sector,
your currency appreciates
and that makes exports
from any other sector really expensive.
So Norway is also an oil rich country,
has tried to circumvent this issue by
when it gets the revenues for its oil,
it doesn't even convert
them into its own currency
but puts them into funds again abroad.
So because Nigeria has all this oil,
its GDP per capita is pretty high,
but we have very high inequality.
And it is one of the top
receivers of Chinese investments.
And those are not just
investments in natural resources.
But I also talked to a lot
of manufacturers there,
people in the service sector
so it's a very attractive market
because you have a huge population,
very cheap land and very cheap labor.
And what's important to note
about Nigeria as well finally
is that it really adapted the
structural adjustment programs
and went with it.
So in 1995 it allowed 100%
foreign ownership in all sectors.
And really, if you're a
foreign investor in Nigeria,
you can basically do whatever you want.
So you can compete with locals,
you can make money there and
you can export it abroad.
So you can really have
a lot of leeway there.
So let's look at growth
and diversification,
as I said like that is
one of our key questions,
is China's presence adding to
growth and diversification?
And here you see that Nigeria actually
just emerged out of a recession.
And that was because of a
drop in global oil prices
and output chalking,
Nigerian and advocate policy
to really respond to this.
And here you see how much Nigeria is,
is really dependent on the oil industry,
because over the past 20 years,
the value added from
industry actually declines
so we don't see any diversification
happening over the past
20 years unfortunately.
So let's hone in a little
bit on how China's presence
is really adding maybe
something to diversification
and local participation in Nigeria.
And what's interesting to
note here is that in 2006,
at another form of
China-Africa cooperation,
China announced that it wants to build
eight special economic zones in Africa.
And that was really based
on this idea that China
used special economic
zones in the beginning
of its opening up to really
experiment with capitalism.
And so they suggested kind
of as a policy strategy,
you should also build these zones
and have tax incentives, tax holidays,
and let's see what
happens but the difference
is that these zones are much
smaller than the ones in China.
So that's why they might
not be working effectively.
But Nigeria got two zones
during this bidding process,
the Lekki Free Trade Zone
and the Ogun Guangdong Zone,
and both are very much
top down joint venture,
joint venture project between
state governments in Nigeria,
as well as Chinese
state owned enterprises.
And I will show you a video now
from the Lekki Free Trade Zone.
- For many African countries,
attracting foreign investments
has always been a challenge.
And now it's become even more difficult
with an economic downturn in
Europe and the United States.
So here's how some African
countries have responded.
They set up what are
known as free trade zones.
These are places where
multinationals can come in,
set up shop and in some cases,
a little or sometimes no tax at all.
It really does beg the question,
what's in it for the ordinary African.
Mark Edwards been checking
up on that in Nigeria,
Africa's most populous nation.
- [Mark] In Lagos they
hope this will be the road
to economic success.
The Lekki Free Trade Zone is being carved
out of thousands of
hectares of untamed land
near the coast of Nigeria's
commercial capital.
- The first part is 3,000 hectares.
- [Mark] They call Sola Oworu
the Empress of the zone.
This former city banker
is in charge of creating
what she believes will become
the Dubai of West Africa.
- The idea is actually to
create a new model city,
not just industrial, also a
residential, commercial area,
so that you have a self sustaining city.
- [Mark] While Lagos
State providing the land,
a Chinese consortium is responsible
for the actual construction.
There's a lot to build.
The zone will have its
own international airport,
deep sea port, and its own
water, power and sewage systems.
- The idea is to have
the zone as a catalyst
for economic development in Lagos State,
diversify the economy,
we would want to attract
foreign direct investments
into Lagos State.
- There are 23 other Free
Trade Zones in Nigeria,
all vying for the attentions
of international investors.
But the Lekki Free
Trade Zone here in Lagos
has one big advantage, size.
At 16,500 hectares it could
become the biggest in Africa,
four times the size of
Manhattan in New York.
- So this is a video from 2013.
And what's striking here is
that you can't really see
the zone itself, right?
So I tried to find videos where you have
some video footage, what
it actually looks like,
but I couldn't so I would
have liked to show you.
So I was wondering about that myself.
So I went to the zone and I
drove there and when you arrive
there's a really nice building in front
with the administration
and like they welcomed me
and I could talk to the MD,
the managing director on the Nigerian side
as well as on the Chinese
side and everyone said,
yeah, the zone is gonna be amazing
and like all of that potential
and it really is going super well.
And then a team of engineers
took me around the zone.
So we came behind the
administration building,
and what you could really
see was not that much,
because there wasn't.
So there was some basic
infrastructure built.
But I was driven around and
I talked to a few companies
that were really only 14 fully operating
Chinese companies in the zone.
And that was after 13 years
of being built, right?
So I think it lags a little
bit behind expectations.
And one of the reasons I see is really,
because it's more of a
top down joint venture
between two governments.
So as I said before,
you have Chinese state
owned enterprise involved.
And it is kind of bound to
this diplomatic relationship
between Nigeria and China
and it is a prestige project.
So that's why they build a
lot of infrastructure there.
But how to make the zone actually
work is a different story.
It is a very profit driven story.
And when I saw kind of
the management building
and then like the office is there,
they're very comfortable in that position,
I don't really see that
big of an incentive to go
out of your way to really
attract all of these companies.
So while there's tax holidays,
so no taxes inside the zone,
there's a very high
management fee actually.
And I talked to companies
that had considered
moving into Lekki Free Trade Zone,
but they didn't find it profitable
because they were too small
for the management fee to make sense.
And finally, they were also
locals that have been protesting
because of resettlements.
'Cause that used to be their land
who have been protesting a lot.
And in 2012 actually,
one of the managers of
the zone got killed.
So they'll have problems to make the zone
really, really work and profitable.
And we have a similar
story for Ogun Guangdong.
So now though I would say it
is performing slightly better.
So it was started with a
Chinese state owned enterprise.
And then they were caught up
in some smuggling problems.
And then a Chinese company
actually took over the zone,
the management of the zones.
And they were more
interested in kind of making
the zone work because they
were more profit driven.
But then the Chinese
government kicked them out,
I believe two years ago and put in again,
a Chinese Special Economic, SOE,
State Owned Enterprise,
because they felt like they
had more control over what
that company could be doing
with this prestige project,
which meant a lot for the
diplomatic relationship
between Nigeria and China.
And there's a very interesting story
that I would like to share with you.
Professor Shapiro and
I, we both separately,
interviewed the private management
at that time of the zone.
And they told us they had one big problem,
which was someone was
blowing up the gas pipelines
that were coming to the zone.
So who do you think was
blowing up these pipelines?
Yes.
No, it was not terrorists.
Yeah.
So what's really interesting
is that you actually had locals
blowing up these gas pipelines
because they started sort
of as a local competition,
or like as a foreign project
that they weren't really
being able to have any advantage of.
So again, have locals seeing the zone
and like seeing the infrastructure,
but not really being able to participate.
And as I said like in Nigeria,
you can kind of just come
in as a foreign company
and you don't have to employ
locals or train locals
or have them on or kind
of give them ownership.
So I've heard a lot of
stories of competition
between Chinese companies
and Nigerian ones.
And obviously competition
is good for kind of growth.
But there's also the flip
side of local inclusion.
So I guess that is the trade off here.
And I know these stories
are just anecdotal.
So I have like, for example,
in the bike ride hailing services,
and there's a really aggressive
Chinese company right now
or in the FinTech industry,
whether a lot of Chinese companies
Offering loans to locals,
just competing on price alone.
And I'm going to conduct
a survey experiment
with Chinese companies
next semester in Nigeria
to kind of get more at the trend here.
So I don't only wanna talk about
negative things about Nigeria,
so they also some positive
developments here.
So for example, Aliko Dangote,
he's the richest African right now.
And what you need to know
about Nigeria is that
it exports all of its crude oil
and imports the refined oil,
because it's not doing the
refining itself domestically.
So Aliko Dangote is now currently building
an oil gas refinery,
in Lekki Free Trade Zone
to solve this problem.
And I talked to locals and
they generally actually feel
positive about it because they're excited
that this is now finally
that there's some domestic refinery here.
I would be a little bit
cautious because 20 years ago,
Nigeria had this law that
not one private businessman
could own that much oil in that industry
just because of national
security concerns, right?
And I think Aliko Dangote
is getting a lot of political
power because of this now,
because he controls,
he can just stop the oil immediately.
He is also, I heard he
wants to also sell it
at kind of international prices.
And if the government
doesn't really comply
with what he wants,
he can just easily export the oil as well,
because he's in the Lekki Free Trade Zone
where they have an airport and a seaport.
But what I'm more excited about
are these small Chinese industrial parks.
And I know you also had to
read an article on this.
Where through an interview,
a local Nigerian broker who
work with Chinese companies,
he invited me to his village and he said,
I live in this village
where the local chief
he set up an industrial park with Chinese
and I should come visit.
So I drove there for a weekend
and I interviewed all the
Chinese companies there
and I also talked to the local chief.
He invited me for tea and
we just sat and chatted.
And this looks like much
more like a bottom up
sort of win-win situation
where in the '90s,
a Chinese businessman, a private one
came to that village and he
wanted to do some fishing there.
So his people they built two
houses for the village chief,
for his palace.
And kind of as an exchange,
he was allowed to fish there
and then he brought more and more people,
small, private Chinese firms
and they build this industrial park.
And they prefer being in
that small industrial park
to being in the big ones
because it's located
on a very strategic street that goes
from the south to the north
and they produce mattresses
and slippers and all of that
and they actually also get tax benefits
from the state government
because the village chief
talks to the state government
and they also employ locals
and have them not as office managers,
but at least as floor managers.
So there seems to be more promise here.
So I wanna contrast the Nigerian
case with the Ethiopian one
and Ethiopia is a country in East Africa.
And I'm comparing it
because it is the second most
populous country in Africa.
So similar in size, it
has never been colonized.
Except for a short period
of where the Italians
occupied Ethiopia during
the Second World War.
It went through a communist era.
But then what's really interesting
is starting in the 1990s,
where you have an
authoritarian regime, arising
the Ethiopian People's
Revolutionary Democratic Front.
And Ethiopia also went through
structural adjustment programs,
but they didn't apply them one to one.
They sort of like China
that also went through
structural adjustment,
took the pieces that they
felt like that would work
in their country and
left everything else out.
So in 2002, they adopted an
industrial policy strategy.
And that transformed into two
growth and transformations
plans that are very much based
on the Chinese and Korean
developmental models.
And when we look at Western
investment flows to Ethiopia,
after 2003, they have like really declined
because there was sort of,
the Western companies
weren't able to just operate
in this market anymore,
because like in China
it was more strategic,
like some sectors were closed,
some are open to foreign investment.
But Chinese investments
stocks meanwhile, rose a lot.
And it's already ranked 11th
for amount of Chinese
investment stocks in Africa.
And I expect it's gonna
join the top 10 very soon.
So when we think about
growth and diversification
in Ethiopia, this is a
much more positive story.
Although Ethiopia is also
starting from a much lower level,
of course, and it's much
poorer than Nigeria,
because it doesn't have this oil wealth.
So now Ethiopia is actually
the fastest growing economy
in Africa right now.
And it's in the news for that a lot.
When we look at industrialization,
this graph looks very positive,
but actually when you compare
over the past 20 years,
the shelf industry has only
grown by I believe it's 11%.
And most of it is coming
from construction,
which is kind of the pre-stage
for industrialization.
So it looks promising,
but we aren't there yet.
And actually, we see a lot of movement
from the agricultural
sector towards services.
So Ethiopia looks more like
India now, than Korea or China,
although it has this
industrialization policy so.
What are some positive developments
here by the Ethiopian government
that were implemented?
So first of all,
Ethiopia has really tried to ramp up
primary education enrollment
over the past 10 years,
and it isn't that 100% now so obviously,
this isn't the perfect
measure of quality education,
but it's one measure to look
at sort of human capital stocks
and then how there's human
capital growing in the economy.
And as I said Ethiopia
is also very strategic
and has a local content initiative
where some sectors are
completely closed off
to foreign investors.
In some sectors, they are open
but there are a lot of
incentives for joint ventures.
And even informal sort of deals.
Investors are always expected
to come up with a strategy
and a proposal of how
locals are going to benefit
from this investment that is being made.
However, there's the study
by Blattman and Dercon,
which I found very interesting.
They tracked industrial workers
in five different factories in Ethiopia,
and actually 70% of them
quit after one year.
So again like there's
potential in Ethiopia
for industrialization,
but it seems like there are more options
still in the agricultural
and informal sectors
and people aren't really picking up these
industrial jobs yet on
or running with them.
So I do think
industrialization is happening
in Ethiopia right now.
But locals should be incentivized
to pick up these jobs
and stay for longer and they
were also health concerns.
So there were a bunch several
blocks to move out of the way.
And here's the Eastern Industry Park.
And this is also one of these eight
Chinese special economic zones
that were placed in Africa,
after China announced they
want to build them in 2006.
But this is a very,
very different approach
to what we saw in Nigeria,
because this is actually a bottom up,
very private initiative.
So it's a private Park.
And there was one Chinese businessman
that came to Ethiopia in 2006.
And he wanted to build a pipe factory.
But then he heard about these biddings
for these special economic zones.
And he applied for one
and he brought one of them to Ethiopia.
And in the beginning,
the Ethiopian government
was very much against it,
it was like very skeptical
of what was happening there.
But this private Chinese businessman,
he brought government
officials from Ethiopia
to see the zones in China.
And over a while the Ethiopian government
really got into this idea
of special economic zones.
And in 2015, they even implemented
industrial zone framework
and they have four more
zones planned now here
and there are 83 Chinese companies
operating in the zone already,
although it's much smaller
than the ones in Nigeria.
So you have some footage from there.
- [Girum] If you look for some of the best
China based companies operating in Africa,
chances are you'll find most
in this humongous industry zone.
Located about 30 kilometers
outside of Ethiopia's capital,
Addis Ababa, the Eastern Industry Zone
is a place for the multi
faceted industries from China.
- This industry is first
industry in Ethiopia.
And this industry is a wide
stage for the foreign investor.
And this one is we get support
from both of Ethiopia
and China government,
because they know in China government,
we have the experience, how
to build these industries,
and how important to attract
the foreign investor.
Also now Ethiopia, they want
to develop the industry.
And now they know.
- [Girum] Since its
inception seven years ago,
the Eastern Industry
Zone has been showcasing
Chinese industrial developments
positive impact here.
The zone now houses best
Chinese manufacturers
such as Huazhan Shoes and Lifan Motors.
Here there is already
a conducive environment
for any investor to operate.
And that according to the management
of the Eastern Industry Zone is key.
- Now Ethiopian they give good condition.
They support us like one stop surveys,
like the customers credit lines,
inside industries, they
give good service very easy.
And the here is peaceful.
- Now the future equally matters
for Ethiopia's manufacturing sector.
There is already a big
ambition to make the nation
Africa's manufacturing hub.
For that Ethiopia eyes the
new Belt and Road Initiative
to make all the dreams a reality.
- So actually there have
been a few academic studies
done on the zone.
And what they found was
that actually companies
are training locals.
Because as I said, the
Ethiopian government sort of
informally requires that
you come up with a proposal
on how locals benefit.
It isn't like for the entire zone,
that there's one sort
of strategy so I think
that could be one improvement here,
but at least you see some development.
That's the locals are being trained
and that local human stocks
of capital are going up.
So I wanna make a final point here
on sort of what's in it
for foreign investors
on obeying with local
participation requirements.
And I wanna talk about the
state of emergency in Ethiopia.
I was actually there during that time.
And basically the state of
emergency broke out after the
Ethiopian government wanted to expand
the borders of Addis Ababa,
the capital to the south
to have like an industrial
kind of area there
and protests broke out in
the Oromo and Amhara regions,
and it cost them ethnic tensions,
and a lot of protests
and arrests, et cetera.
And during these protests,
locals really went to foreign
companies and destroyed them
because they felt like
they weren't part of this
growth story that
Ethiopia was telling them
and also you could hear in Western media.
So I had a very interesting
story from an interviewee there
that there was Aliko Dangote,
which is the richest man of
Africa had one factory there.
And right next to it was a
Dutch South African factory.
And what's really
interesting is the protesters
walked around the Dutch
South African factory
and destroyed Aliko Dangote's factory.
Why?
Because the Dutch South African factory,
they employed a lot of locals,
also gave them shares from the company.
It was perceived as a local project.
So in some sense, if you
incorporate kind of local partners,
it also mediates political risks.
So let's now turn over to the lessons
that we can draw from
these two case studies.
So first of all I think the central lesson
is that deal conditions matter
for development outcomes.
And going back to this first question
that we had in beginning,
like is China new colonialist?
Or can it sort of put its model in Africa
and then now Africa is gonna rise,
I really think that this
is more about African side,
strategizing rather than the
Chinese dictating any model,
and you see that in different
sort of policy environments.
The Chinese are gonna act very differently
as international actors are
gonna act differently as well.
So I think it's more
sort of African agency
that is going to determine whether
this is a positive or a
negative China-Africa story.
I also doubt that there's
one China-Africa story,
because we have 54
different African countries,
but very different policies.
And the conventional wisdom
here is actually on these
two conditions that African
countries can't set them
because they have to be deal takers
in order to attract any
kind of foreign capital.
And this is very much this
Washington Consensus Narrative,
the Poverty Trap Narrative,
that the region historically
has not been able
to attract significant
amounts of investment.
So you have to make it as easy
for foreign investors as
possible to kind of attract them.
This is because Africa's
population is young
and under educated, low
stocks of human capital
poor infrastructure and political risk,
sort of what Jeffrey Sachs
laid out in his piece.
And even with China in the picture,
the African countries
still have no exit options
to the Chinese offer, right?
So it's kind of this idea of
whatever the Chinese offering,
you have to accept,
because there's no one
else who will step in
and build this for you.
So as I said,
I conducted 10 months of
field research in Africa,
kind of to try to find evidence for this.
And now based on the
evidence that I found,
I highly doubt this entire narrative.
And I say that paradoxically,
I believe African countries actually
have significant bargaining
power with China.
And I think this is
fundamentally based on the idea
that Africa doesn't just
have all these weaknesses,
that the poverty trap
list here, but in fact,
Africa is the region in the world
with the most amount of natural resources.
The cheapest labor in the
world and the cheapest land.
And in contrast to the West,
China has both willingness
and capacity right now
at its developmental stage,
to put its money into Africa
and to really get returns
from these factors that look
very attractive and lucrative
to China here.
So completely, China has
massive capital surpluses
as I said and it needs raw
material to fuel its growth.
Africa is the last
region to industrialize.
So as I said, I interviewed a
lot of Chinese manufacturers
that are really excited
about the African markets,
because it's so much cheaper
there to run a factory now.
Africa also has export
deals with the UN, the US.
So actually, when they
want to export goods,
they don't have to pay any tariffs.
So as a Chinese if you produce in Africa,
it is cheaper for you
and in a lot of cases.
What's also interesting,
I want to focus data in
and I interviewed someone
who is still in Nigeria and the
President said that in 2016,
China increased its
environmental regulations
in symmetric market.
And in that year,
you saw a lot of Chinese companies
that did not want to obey
with these environmental
regulations to Africa because,
for example Nigeria doesn't have these
strict government regulations.
And finally, Chinese
companies also seem to be
less risk averse to political instability.
So you also have a lot
of Chinese investments
in South Sudan, for example,
which is not politically very stable.
So I think that Western investors
are much more sensitive,
they also stay to these kind of political
and safety concerns.
They stay a lot of urban areas,
where you see a lot of
Chinese in rural areas.
And I think that what's
the most important is that
certain concerns with Western investment
that limit African bargaining power,
are less alien with Chinese one.
So first of all,
you could argue that
because China is offering
all these loans to Africa,
it makes these African countries
very dependent on China.
But actually Deborah Brautigam,
who is one of the leading scholars here,
she wrote a lot on this and saying,
the magnitude of this
is really overstated.
And then you see countries like
Ethiopia who have taken out
much more debt with China
actually being more aggressive
with China than others
which are smaller debtors like Nigeria.
Secondly, China is also really trying
to compete with the West.
And the number of allies matters.
Also at the UN we see
that UN General Assembly,
these African countries on certain things
they vote with China.
And if you're Ghana or if you're Nigeria,
you have the same vote,
it's one country, one vote.
So that's why China's interested
in having a relationship
with all these countries
and economic relationship
and there is the loan,
trade and investment.
And I think this is very
important for the central point
here that these African countries,
there's less of a need for
intercontinental competition
for Chinese investments
because it seems less rivalrous
than what's coming from the West.
And even if China's the
only sort of investor here,
China oftentimes prefers
to be in your economy,
than not be in your economy.
Even if they have to
adapt slightly to policies
that countries imposing
and you see this year,
you see investment stocks from
the US where like you have
maybe five countries where
the top receivers and the rest
is getting very little.
And there's a lot of competition
here for US investment.
But when you look at Chinese
investment stocks in Africa,
the first ones surely to get more,
but then you have a much
more even distribution
of those investment pies,
and you have 51 African countries
that actually receive an investment pie.
And yes, that is dependent
on sort of China's political
and economic considerations.
But I run some regressions
and it is very independent
of whether African countries
are imposing local participation
requirements or not.
And let's take one of
these investment pies.
Let's say Zimbabwe.
And let's see what a policy
shock does to these investments.
So in 2008, Zimbabwe implemented this
Indigenisation and
Economic Empowerment Act,
where all companies inside Zimbabwe
had to have 51% of local ownership.
And when we look at US
investment flows here,
investment stocks in Zimbabwe,
you see that after 2006,
they were not even counted anymore
because they really decreased a lot.
And I found a lot of qualitative evidence
from Western companies here,
complaining about 51%
local ownership all of that
and it just made Zimbabwe
very, very uncompetitive
compared to African countries.
And of course,
you also have the financial
crisis hit here in 2008.
That also is part of the story.
But when you look at Chinese
investment stocks here,
they really don't seem
to be bothered by the 51%
local ownership here where
you see starting in 2010,
these stocks really skyrocket.
So this is puzzling and then
when we look at Algeria,
we have the exact same
policy change also in 2008,
with 50% of local ownership
required with companies.
And here you see, starting in 2007,
when these were announced it really like
the curve really gets much more flat
versus Chinese investment stocks.
They just you have that
upward sloping trend line regardless.
And I also conducted a lot of interviews
with Chinese businesses
and Western businesses,
try and get at these sensitivities,
to local participation requirements.
And really, across the board,
when I asked the Chinese
they were just like,
honestly, like as I said,
this is China in the '70s and '80s.
And it's great here,
I would stay under any
kind of policy regulations.
Versus when you ask a Western investor,
they were like no, like
if I had to employ locals,
I would think about it twice.
And I found this quote
from Algeria as well.
So the question is,
why do some countries like Nigeria, Kenya,
negotiate weaker deals
in the sense of like,
diversification issues
and local participation,
weaker deals with China than others
like Ethiopia and Tanzania?
And I think common explanations here are,
for example corruption
that countries know that
they could be asking for more
from the Chinese investors,
but they aren't because
politicians like to just pocket
some money and let them
do whatever they want.
Or another explanation is ideology
so that they know they could
be imposing these restrictions
and the Chinese would be doing it
but let's just keep the economy open
because we really support capitalism
and let market forces do their job.
Or capacity where the government
knows they could be asking
for more but they don't have
trained or skilled negotiators
that can face sort of
the Chinese negotiators
that have more experience.
But I would like to bring
up a new explanation here,
which is the government's perceptions
on their own bargaining power matter.
And why could this be
one of the explanations?
I mean, it isn't exactly
obvious that these economies
do have bargaining power, right?
Like we just talked
about all the weaknesses
and how the Washington Consensus
and the Poverty Trap
Narrative really suggests
that these countries are negotiating
from a position of weakness.
So I conducted interviews,
especially very, very
intensively in Nigeria,
to understand how the Nigerian
government thinks about
Chinese companies and
how Chinese companies
think about the Nigerian
government in terms of kind of
policy sensitivity and exit thresholds
and of what would be the policies
that would drive the Chinese out.
And the Nigerian government I
interviewed national ministers
who told me honestly, we have
no bargaining power here.
The Chinese and the West,
they're bringing all the money
and we have nothing to offer.
So we kind of just have let
them do whatever they want to,
versus with the Chinese companies,
as I said, I got a lot of them just said,
you know, I would do everything
to be able to stay here.
And in other countries like Tanzania,
there was much more of this awareness,
this China really needs us.
And then Ethiopia I've heard that a lot
like we are really pulling
the Chinese in here right now
because we have cheap labor
and we have cheap land.
And this is exactly what China
is looking for right now.
So what are the factors that
influence African governments'
perceptions on bargaining power?
And I tried to understand the
political economy behind this.
So first of all,
I think the historic
relationship to the West
versus the East matters to where I said,
Nigeria was a British
colony for a very long time.
And we went through the
Washington Consensus and really
adapted what Western
investors were telling Nigeria
at that time,
versus Ethiopia had never been colonized.
Tanzania also has
a very long historical
relationship with China.
They've looked very much
more towards the East
also during the Cold War.
There is also federalism
and ministry constellation
where in Nigeria, a lot
of different states,
they actually compete for investments.
So they're not likely
to share information,
how much Chinese investment
is actually coming in.
And a lot of them really
underestimated Nigeria's position
and attractiveness to China.
And it's the same with
ministry constellation,
where in Nigeria you
have a lot of ministries
sort of competing for these deals,
and there's not one collaborative effort
versus when you have one sort of
very centralized government.
That government has all the information
on sort of what investment comes in.
And it's also overtime learning
if you have one party in
power for a long time,
they might have tested out
kind of what can we asked
for also more informal deals.
And then finally individual
agency also matters,
where I've just met people,
for example in Tanzania,
someone in a very senior
position in the ministry.
He was educated in Japan,
and just really studied industrial policy
through and through.
And he just knew, he was very confident
that China was going
to obey by these rules
if Tanzania asked for them.
And Tanzania also has
similar policies to Ethiopia.
So what are some policy implications here?
I just think incentives
are more effective than requirements.
Mostly because when you look
at these different graphs
from the West and China,
you're trying to attract
two different kinds
and types of investors.
So if you offer like a menu
like Ethiopia has here,
different types of investors
can pick whatever they like the most.
So if I care more about low taxes,
maybe I'm more willing to have
a joint venture and so forth.
So you can kind of mix
up different policies
and offer a different menu to
different types of investors
that can pick whatever they wanna do.
I think because these countries also have
weak formal policies,
it leaves room for a
case-by-case negotiations
as we see, for example,
with these industrial parks
that I talked about.
The hidden industrial
parks of the villages
that kind of set up a deal
that work for all sides.
And you should also account
for enter and exit thresholds
where I think the decision of companies
to enter your country, are probably,
they're more sensitive to kind
of your policy environment
rather than if you're
already in the country.
And then certainly, you
have to pay higher taxes.
So your decision to exit
because you already set up
kind of a factory, et cetera.
It's gonna be less sensitive
than if you still need to put
in all the capital in the beginning.
So what are some
expectations for the future?
So I think there's
certain things to consider
on the Chinese side.
Which is can China maintain its
growth but I also heard that
because China's growth is slowing
now all these Chinese
manufacturers are moving to Africa
in search for new opportunities,
and they feel like the African region
is the next one to industrialize.
So it's kind of, literature
here is not clear whether
China slowing its growth,
is actually good or bad
for the African region.
How its rivalry will play out with the US.
And what about automation
and the flying geese.
So I think that's something
we should be concerned about
that if labor is being
replaced with machines,
maybe the cheap labor in
Africa is gonna be less needed.
So factors on the African side,
I think the biggest question is,
can countries start to
use their bargaining power
and negotiate stronger deals?
And just coming up with a strategy,
I think here is essential,
rather than just leaving
the entire economy open
and letting investors
do whatever they want.
Sort of what China did when
it was poor and agricultural.
It did come up with a strategy
that propelled up the economy.
And I think this is
interesting on debts and trade,
because as I said,
at the former China-Africa
cooperation in 2008,
African countries already complained
that there was an in trade imbalance
between China and Africa and that China
should also import more
from the African region.
So it seems like around debts and trade,
there is more of an awareness
that this relationship
should be more equal.
And I hope that investments also are going
into the right direction.
So just to close,
I brought you this comparison here again,
which shows very nicely,
China's economic growth miracle.
And what I find really interesting
here is that in the '80s,
it was really the West investing in China
and doing a lot of trade with China,
but we still don't call
it the West in China,
how we call China in Africa today.
And this is because China
took some lessons from
other countries in the past,
like some of the structural adjustment,
it's liked and implemented others,
it came up with the zones model,
which was the state capitalism.
And I think similarly,
the African region also
can just copy and paste
one model from China now or from the West,
but it should strategize
and see sort of what fits to
local realities and the
common narrative here
has always been that
the African region can't
afford to strategize
because otherwise you can't really attract
foreign investment to grow.
But I think because Africa
is the region that has
the highest stocks of raw
material in the world,
the cheapest labor right
now and the cheapest land,
I do think that there's some leverage here
for the African region.
And hopefully in the future,
we can recolor this map
and the African region
can catch up with China.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
(soft music)